I don't want a query I stay right here
dude do I hit it up or they open all
your stuff all my rocks
take one nice thing that was there man
like I want to hear like it just spent
millions of dollars in one-time about
this piece back piece they come see me
I didn't voice comes him again I might
get a chance come see me again my better
I want to go crazy I might get to chimes
you know you just add up over the course
in here the hardest took me like I say
about oh you're this one Oh like over
nice and sneeze like alright you got
this first my utter surprise stuff is
put up I don't have it with me but this
one over this part of the collection
it's like my whole goes to the bubble
levels it made sense to me and it is
nothing more kidding I just want to look
fun I like if you look at this you can
tell like it looks fun you look at this
you could hit it with a serious like
Sims you guys look seared like don't
play with me
that's how fun if account is my label I
had sinus EMG which is collected so I
was like oh gotta help I'm in position
you know to become successful though I'm
a star something to help other people
become successful so I thought of
allowing it with ever come let me give
people opportunity sign way I was given
the opportunity anybody want to go in
here can't wanna be part of this I say
just stay focused and to not chase the
money chase the dream every second
raising money gonna come so horny know
better around me to my own bro I need
some money
I know you broke now you got you got a
grind guys you got me
come be like I ain't got time for it
[Music]
the Big Dipper the big oh my god
okay it's the Big Dipper it's like real
special to me bars like chill now this
is not Chinese song it's part like the
most expensive time I the boat if you
notice it's a heavy camp and detail
going all around
I just kept a layers to it so I'm like
first we started with just the top part
all right now I want some s on it now
put the levels on top of and like the
dam is out right now because I love
baguette
yeah I do but getting that date I can
show you the difference this look more
crunched up versus this right here going
on this on crunch total date they they
take these products them look to make
the next 300 G's they can't afford this
it's not see [ __ ]
300 when you do this when my hurt is
behind suit so it's another one it was a
bracelet in a hub Chinese and so what I
did I made Nick cut it and make me a
break I don't have a bracelet with me
they're running but this where I hurt to
me honey the brace like a honey bath
I got some ones you're like I don't even
like words you're the reason why cause
like I'm glad I'm able to explain is to
so when I go on stage I used to put all
my jerk I'd be jumping I go I like the
format for it I don't like looking cool
trying to look flat so I use like all my
damages to be coming out I got tired of
spending the money so how long we were
one [ __ ] on stage and won't watch I'm
not gonna talk I just got this one this
is my rolling out watch I was going on
stage to do my show and I have got like
amazing news
sighing abandons watchful Nick I just
don't like a celebration I think for me
feeling good hey this will roll leak so
I heard I think that's when I heard like
cars like a 55 this one like 65 70 he's
just too uppity it's like but when I
bought it was like I paid like 92 I
think it's like 115 right now gonna wind
up about two of these watches all right
one when I'm in LA
I'm q1 when I'm in Memphis they were not
be coming shopping with you I won't even
look at the time I don't know how to say
the time guess with my hair it's another
Cuban this to happen but it's not it's
not the house so sometimes what you can
fool you like just because they weigh
more they don't mean it comfortable
I want something stand out so we have to
come up with this right here where I can
stand out I got all different type of
stones and her like somebody's down
there really too big the behavior but I
forced a minute hold on I want some
peace tones when I stand beside you I
want to be like are you digging Bullis
doing
I have a lot of braces they'd be too
heavy on my wrists I start with this one
here mr. bigshot I heard this is my big
shot
it makes my Cuban right here it's like
I'm hunting right this is my herd just
like the new swag I guess going on with
her I only know the name but what it is
I got three of those three hours to down
our one two three blister heart is you
probably live near like maybe like a
cold immediately woke gotta take online
yeah you looking at my car by 275 I like
this it's one of my favorite so it's
like one hot guy see yeah I see
it's a big one right her I spent like
for the traditional on her alone it's my
mini time I heard it's like fun going
somewhere like overseas and I wanna have
too much here on me and [ __ ] like people
to rob you it's another the sign sizes
SS the minimum thing cause like kids
hang out like 15 apiece and this might
this adult leave like 30 I got another
dog I ain't even vote easy is you can
see I got hoes murder I got hold of
someone someone forced me to get hos
Scott and then you look who unique
everything oh my god you look so pretty
on my car the earrings you so sacred
shots so I got everything personally and
I got him lying like I'm label to him so
these were her and you want no tea cups
get like I hunt down a piece I might go
so waiting with his own a wig
Mabel friend or somebody like I don't
really go to many places like Mario
knows me her BAE
I car like the beats
[Music]
I mean it's a tiny surgery
I never been in surgery I already had
girls like when I was young so I know
what they do the old manner and I had a
Mitchell T foot benefit go gums
I hate car like gum disease if you saw
my other video you got covering my teeth
majority of you see what grill they
brush tankers cook yeah you know you
know you wake up in the morning time
Spanky they like nighttime strike in the
next couple years I'm going see at
Hardee's back and get all my money back
it's my plan that's why I spend back
good quarter diamonds and I go to the
airport they tell you a message on
surgery shoulder blade like you got an
ex artist is like hey when you go to the
airport what Carrillo juror be if they
show a blue is fake if you sure black is
real so maybe we should do airport uh
anniversary me you mean you go to the
airport they don't stop with like a
man's real it was popping this is port
Blake nostril
I appreciate it about to near my cheek
your interview cockers I don't say